at the edge of the seven Carpathian
Mountains forest rangers Daniel who da
Xue and Matteo Michaelis COO are braving
the snow and freezing temperatures in
search of one of the continents largest
inhabitants the recent or European bison
they locate the herd in a mountain
meadow most of the animals were released
here just a short time ago it's really
something special to be able to CV since
in the wild again they were raised in
captivity and we've released them into
these forests so many years after the
species disappeared from the area the
last animal of its kind to roam this
range was killed around 200 years ago
ever since then the European bison was
extinct in the wild reintroducing the
genus proof challenging human beings
pose the greatest threat to the large
herbivores more and more villages are
spreading into the reasons habitat
cameras set up by conservationists
observe the herd in this footage dogs
from surrounding villages have formed a
pack and are hunting the animals their
owners leave the dogs to find their own
food the emaciated canines see the half
domesticated bison as a ready meal
project leader Audra and Hatice is still
optimistic he's hoping that large herds
will soon be roaming through the
Carpathians but for this to succeed he
needs the support of the villagers exist
though we started reintroducing reasons
into the wild we worked hard to
integrate local people in the process to
ensure they would accept the project and
it appears that little by little the
surrounding communities are becoming
accustomed to their new neighbors
we pay a visit to a village with one of
the Rangers deer wild boar and the
occasional bear are nothing unusual
around here but the reasons which can
weigh up to a ton are something new
this one has made itself a home in a
farmer's barnyard the hay is tasty and
provides a warm place to sleep he was
cast out by the herd when it was near
this village so he came straight here
now he's found a place to stay for the
time being
the Rangers talked to farmers who have
reported Close Encounters and try to
reassure them I got close to the animal
and wanted to give it some bread and he
came at me with his horns it's scared of
daylights out of me the animals have
eaten everything conservationists have
their work cut out for them when it
comes to persuading the farmers to
welcome their new neighbors it'll still
be some time before the Bison have
resettled here deep in the forests of
the southern carpathians
you